i do not view abortion as a
as a choice and a right i think it's
always a tragedy and i think that
it should be rare and safe and i think
we should be focusing on how to limit
the number of abortions and they ought
to be able to have a common ground and
consensus is to do that i think the vast
majority of the american people think
that can be done um but unfortunately
we're put in a position to either
eliminate abortions under all
circumstances or it's quote abortion on
demand the fact of the matter is i've
never known of a woman have an abortion
to say by the way i feel like having an
abortion it's always a tragic decision
made always a difficult decision
all right people how you doing
uh there's a lot going on today
i thought that maybe today there
wouldn't be a lot going on was feeling
good after yesterday hadn't been in
studio for two weeks did a thick show i
even showed you it was the thickest
stack of paper i had ever had it was our
longest show ever yesterday had a big
day being back here at home dealing with
some stuff
about nine o'clock yesterday watching
the
seinfeld on netflix it was the uh the
ugly baby episode it's feeling good
about life
and then my phone starts blowing up
roe v wade people
we got a big one for you it's may 3rd
2022 i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message we are live
streaming on rumble youtube and blaze tv
uh subscribe over on the rumble channel
if you have not already and yeah there
is a lot going on that little cold open
that we just showed you there that was
uh joe biden back in 2006 when he was
obviously a lot sharper than he is at
the moment and not only sharper i would
say more moderate
more sensible uh and
trying to deal with a complex issue
in a roughly honest way the reason we
wanted to do that as the cold open was
because he did say one particular word
in there
that i thought was interesting because
he said the word right and he said that
he this is joe biden back in 2006 did
not believe that abortion was a right
that's what he just said you can rewind
it after the live stream if you want um
which is sort of interesting because
obviously roe v wade was about making
abortion
a federal
right now maybe he just slightly
misspoke there
but today what i'm going to try to do
is calmly explain what roe v wade is
what this decision that appears to be
coming to fruition because the decision
was leaked which is another huge problem
related to all this what this all means
and and what has been happening state by
state
anyway and all of this in many ways
fits so well with uh
this thing right over here that i've
been telling people about that we don't
want to burn this country we don't want
to burn all of our institutions that if
you don't get what you want it doesn't
give you the right to upend the entire
system destroy the branches of
government destroy the systems that have
worked pretty well for 250 years the
systems that have expanded freedoms to
more people over time and that we should
be able to honestly discuss
the most difficult things and i would
say abortion in many cases is right at
the top of that list i mean is there
anything
that brings out the emotion
all of the the existential issues the
philosophical issues the political
issues the religious issues is there
anything that does it more than abortion
and can good people on be on both sides
of this issue
and still talk about it it's getting
harder and harder to do that with
literally everything much less something
that is
about life and death so i'm going to try
to do that here and uh we will see how i
do that is not for me to decide that
will be
for you to decide uh but real quick if
you haven't picked up the book yet we go
into this like we go into all of this
stuff you can go to daverubin.com
book and pick up a copy and of course
i'm heading back out on tour uh next
week there's i think ten tickets left uh
for the brea show with dennis prager
there's a couple left for larry elder in
oxnard almost all of them are basically
sold out at this point but coupled seats
in each one douglas murray in san jose
blake masters and charlie kirk will be
joining me in phoenix brian callan in
denver and then the big one
which we announced yesterday florida
governor ron desantis will be joining me
on june
2nd in orlando in disney country as they
call it at the plaza live you can go to
davereuben.com
events uh and pick up some tickets so
okay so it's gonna be a big show i
promise i'm gonna do everything i can
like we really went through it this
morning like how can we do this honestly
and decently so that people when they
watch the program today will be able to
have a conversation either at work or at
the dinner table or with the crazy
person on the street and explain the
issues honestly so that's what we are
going to do today real quick guys i want
to talk to you about bullying max you
know as inflation surpasses highs not
seen in 40 years the value of the dollar
is decreasing with every passing day
you're paying more at the pump at the
grocery store for cars and for housing
face it paper money is just worth less
friends the time couldn't be better for
my new sponsor bullion max bullion max
is a direct to consumer precious metals
retailer who can help you diversify into
gold and silver it's a hedge against
inflation it's also security for your
family in times of crisis and here's why
i love bullying max they're owned by
veterans in the precious metal space
offer some of the lowest prices on the
internet and they make it so easy to buy
directly from their website i want to
help you guys get started so i worked
out a special deal with them just for
you go to bullion max you can get
billion max's silver starter kit at
employee pricing just go to
bullionmax.com dave this kit includes
five of the most desirable silver
products to invest in including a silver
american eagle and a silver australian
kangaroo this offer is limited to just
one per household so get yours now go to
bullionmax.com
dave and now back to me okay so let's
just do the nuts and bolts stuff of what
happened last night got some quotes here
from the daily wire
late on monday evening may 2nd politico
broke a world shattering story it posted
an exclusive leak of a purported
majority opinion in dobbs vs mississippi
2022 the case considering whether or not
roe v wade from 1973 which created out
of whole cloth a right to abortion ought
to be overruled the majority opinion was
written by justice samuel alito it
rejected in totality both row and the
entire chain of cases following their
from including pan parenthood planned
parenthood versus casey from 92
and the draft decision states it is time
to heed the constitution and return the
issue of abortion to the people's
elected representatives this is what the
constitution and the rule of law demand
the draft opinion which is almost
certainly authentic it reads just like
justice alito and utterly dismantles the
legal non-reasoning of roe and casey
would amount to a reversion of all
abortion law to the state level where it
originally resided as the decision
concludes abortion presents a profound
moral question the constitution does not
prohibit the citizens of each state from
regulating or prohibiting abortion rowan
casey arrogated that authority we now
overrule those decisions and return that
authority to the people and their
elected representatives okay so let's do
some basic 101 stuff here because a lot
of people and our very very negligent
media is going to be telling you that
this makes abortion illegal all over the
country that is simply not what it does
before roe v wade before that decision
in 1973 abortion was left up to the
state so the state legislatures could
decide the people would vote for their
politicians and then the states would
make decisions related to abortion roe v
wade eventually made it to the supreme
court and that decision made abortion a
federal right meaning the states could
not outlaw abortion
from beat one when it came to roe v wade
there were even pro-choice people who
felt that this was not a sound decision
meaning that it is not in the purview of
the federal government there is nothing
in the constitution that says that the
federal government has the right to tell
the states what to do regarding abortion
there's just nothing in there that says
it so there were even pro-choice
activists that said that
okay so that's one thing so reversing
this
assuming this is all true and now it
seemingly is coming out that this is all
true this leak and i'll get to the leak
in just a second all this does is kick
abortion back to the state so it is no
longer federally mandated that it has to
be legal now what's interesting about
that and i often talk about the
experiment of the united states of
america right that there's this ongoing
experiment where states decide to do
different things and some states say
florida have no income tax some states
like california have high income tax
some states have different laws related
to policing or education or a series of
other things so there's this constant
experiment going on in america this
beautiful experiment related to freedom
and you can decide if you want to live
in a certain place related to whether it
fits in line with how you want to live
your life that is a beautiful thing and
it's something that most places
virtually no other western nation has it
the way we have it i assure you the
people of canada the people in western
canada would love to have it so that not
all the decisions uh were coming out of
the rest of the country right this is
this is something that allows people in
a free nation of 350 million people like
we have in america to all make decisions
roughly freely so just to be very very
clear
reversing roe v wade is not making
abortion legal now the states will
decide what to do now what's interesting
about this and what is so
dangerous about what just happened
because of it happening through elite is
the states have sort of been doing this
anyway
right here in florida they passed
florida passed this the state
legislature passed a 15-week abortion
ban now they couldn't pass a full
abortion ban nor do i think the people
of florida would have even wanted a full
abortion ban but they passed a 15-week
abortion ban now there's four months uh
there's four weeks in a month and so
that's over three months right it's
three and a half months into a pregnancy
they said 15 weeks that is
by my estimation very fair now we can
get into all of the the stuff about when
life starts and i can tell you as
someone having kids right now there has
to be a beginning to it and the
beginning basically is the sperm meets
the egg right there if there's a
beginning that's it and then the
question that we're really all debating
is are those in those first few weeks as
you have cells just dividing and you can
see it under a microscope is that the
same exact thing as say when you have
the form of a human body when you have a
heartbeat when you have brain activity
all of those things when the fetus can
feel pain now we can all debate how we
all feel about that my personal belief
and this is just my personal belief is
that there is a difference between those
first few weeks when cells are just
dividing and there is no form versus
perhaps when there's form uh heartbeat
et cetera et cetera but i get those
those are personal beliefs and i also
think that in a in a pluralistic society
like we have in america where you have
people of all sorts of religions and
beliefs and all sorts of things
that you have to have some room on the
margins and that's where it gets messy
and that's what gets people so upset
okay so be it but the point is that
one more time to be totally clear this
is not making abortion illegal what is
going to happen assuming this is all
going the way that it seems it's going
is that there will be states like
california that will become abortion
havens right they will have abortion
parks in essence that's what gavin
newsom will want there that's what the
lefty people will want and they'll want
eight month abortions and nine month
abortions and post-birth abortions and
they will welcome people to come there
for abortions i don't think there's
actually going to be many states that
completely 100 percent outlaw abortion
without exceptions you know talking
about rape or health to the mother or
you know a fetus that is not
cannot be fully actualized etc etc what
i think you're going to get are a bunch
of red states that are going to do
something similar to what florida just
did they will have reasonable
and again it doesn't matter if you agree
or not something like roughly reasonable
laws so texas may have something closer
to say 10 weeks and florida will have 15
weeks and then within those weeks they
might have some exceptions related to
health of the mother after that point et
cetera et cetera but this
gives some level
of choice right it's always the lefties
that are saying that they're for choice
but ironically this is where the choice
is coming so what's unfortunate about
this
this decision because it's going to
become so polarizing and there's no
doubt we're going to see violence and
wait till i get to some of the democrats
that want to burn down the system now is
that it's sort of been happening while
no state could outlaw abortion
and personally i think that is good it
is possible now that let's say and i'm
just picking one off the top of my head
let's say alabama 100
bans abortion with no exceptions and
everything else well you can still go
and get an abortion elsewhere and all of
the rich hollywood celebrities that
seemingly love abortion or think this is
about women's rights or my body my
choice which of course they didn't
believe during
covet vaccine mandates
they can fund people to go to california
and go elsewhere and get abortions now i
think over time that's going to become a
problem because as a bunch of rich
lefties keep funding basically young
black girls 16 year old black girls on
buses to come to cali to get abortions
the optics of that may not be all that
great but the point is there will be
choice and i think there will be very
few states that 100 percent outlaw it
but what will happen is states will make
decisions for themselves which is
exactly how it was before
1973 and one more time i say that as
someone that is begrudgingly pro-choice
and i suspect that most of my audience
is not i that would be my guess i
honestly i'm not even totally sure i can
tell you that when i wrote don't burn
this book the first book that when i
took the begrudging pro-choice
position
that a lot of you wrote to me that you
loved the book and you just agree
disagreed with me about abortion but you
said dave i still dig you and i'll still
follow what you do and perhaps you'll
come more my way over time or maybe i'll
go your way over time but probably not
but that's what it's all about that's
what america is all about so okay
that's sort of where we're at at the
moment abortion is not illegal if this
all goes through oh and i should address
the um the leak part of this the the
fact that this was leaked either by one
of the supreme court justices themselves
or by a clerk or if there was somehow a
hack into the system at the supreme
court this is an absolutely
extraordinary escalation of the sort of
general damage that our society has
right now this is bad stuff um if a
supreme court justice intentionally
leaked it and my guess is not that that
it probably was a clerk right it was
probably one of the lefty clerks who
works for one of the people say justice
sotomayor who was unhappy with what was
gonna happen and then they leak it and
now we're gonna have weeks of sort of
this craziness um this is really bad
news you cannot be a clerk for a supreme
court justice or a local judge or
anything else and be leaking decisions
before they have been announced like
this person needs to be caught and fired
and punished to the fullest extent of
the law without question but okay so
let's move on so here we are at the
moment where it looks like this is all
legit and real and what of course is
this leading to this is leading to
the mainstream left which has become the
far left there there virtually are no
decent liberals anymore you
know that well if you watch this program
this has sort of exposed them for what
they are so here is joy reid over at the
televised mental institution known as
nbc and of course what did she retweet
tomorrow would be a good day to expand
the supreme court so now you need to
understand what they want to do here
they did not get a decision that they
like when they get a decision they like
they're good to go and they believe in
rule of law when you don't get a
decision that you like you should upend
everything we should put more judges on
who do what we want this is the reverse
of how a free society would work we have
three branches of government i know aoc
doesn't know them all
but we have the legislative branch which
which writes laws
we have the executive branch which signs
them into law and then we have the
judicial branch which reviews them and
figures out what is legal and what is
not if you decide to just break down a
branch because it doesn't do what you
want and pack a court so you get more
people who just think the way you think
then you're not for democracy right
you're not for this entire experiment i
don't think they're for this entire
experiment so actually it's nice when
they kind of tell you that they're not
for it ilhan omar who also is not for
this great american experiment even
though she's a first generation somali
immigrant who has
garnered extraordinary power and
influence here in america just doesn't
like the place very much she said
overturning roe would put the lives of
women across the country at risk it
would fly in the face of decades of
precedent and the overwhelming majority
of public opinion and they will not stop
here expand the court so again this
expand the court mean this is going to
be the big meme that they're going for
they are really going to be pushing this
idea can we just pack the court with
people that we want can you pull the
tweet up one more time because i want to
get to the second part of what she said
she said the overwhelming majority of
public opinion i don't know that that's
true i actually don't know exactly what
public opinion the overwhelming majority
that would sound like it was 65 or 70
of people that are pro-choice it's
usually from what you can tell it's it's
pretty close to 50-50 and then there's
but you know there's that little gray
area in the middle in terms of when
people are okay with abortion when
they're not etc etc um
so i you know but she's ilhan omar so
nothing she says is honest and speaking
of nothing being honest here's aoc uh as
we've warned scotus isn't coming for
abortion they're coming for the right to
privacy row rests on which includes gay
marriage and civil rights okay that's
complete nonsense i'll get to the
specifics of the nonsense in just a
second um but the court wrote megyn
kelly let's let's pull it up right now
so megyn kelly actually highlighted uh
some of the decision
uh here and some of the the words that
samuel alito wrote himself and the third
part
that she highlighted there is the key
part of all of this
it says and to ensure that our decision
is not misunderstood or mischaracterized
we emphasize that our decision concerns
the constitutional right to abortion and
no other right nothing in this opinion
should be understood to cast doubt on
precedents that do not concern abortion
in other words if another case makes it
up to the supreme court they can't look
at this case and say this has anything
to do with say gay marriage or civil
rights or anything else so there's no
reason to believe that suddenly they're
going to be coming for civil rights that
suddenly
you're going to have laws that stop
black people from doing something or
from gay people from doing something or
anything else now i can see already
what's going to happen here that there's
going to be all these people screaming
about gay marriage so let me just say a
couple things about the gay marriage
thing first off if you remember before
june of 2015 when the supreme court
decided the gay marriage case
it was happening across the states can
you can we check on that how many states
had gay marriage passed already by the
time the supreme court did it i think it
was 20 something states remember if you
remember that year there were states
that were just going ahead and doing it
properly state by state by state and
then the supreme court got involved and
said it is a federal right now the
difference
is that in the supreme court's decision
on gay marriage they talked about
specific clauses in the constitution
that were the basis for the law which
roe v wade did not have roe v wade just
said hey it's a constitutional right to
have an abortion but
in the case it was obergfell versus
hodges and let's pull up some info from
cornell law on gay marriage here's the
exact info obergefell versus hodges is a
landmark case in which on june 26 2015
june 26 was my birthday by the way the
supreme court of the united states held
in a 5-4 decision that state bans on
same-sex marriage and on recognizing
same-sex marriages duly performed in
other jurisdictions are unconstitutional
under the due process and equal
protection clauses of the 14th amendment
to the united states constitution
meaning that in essence because of equal
protection and due process that we have
a system that exists that there are laws
that exists and all people are to be
treated equally
in this case if you had been married in
a state that allowed for gay marriage
that another state was going to have to
recognize it there was there it was
based in something now interestingly
thank you guys 37 states had already
made decisions through their own
legislatures almost all the states had
made their decisions on gay marriage
before the scotus ruling had scotus the
supreme court of the united states
obviously had they not made the decision
on gay marriage gay marriage was was
happening and would have been basically
probably 48 or maybe even 49 states but
the point is they are specifically
saying in this decision you cannot look
at this decision and go to anything else
and what i'm trying to also add is that
the decision on gay marriage was
actually based on something again equal
protection clause
uh and equal protection under the law so
that that is just one little calm
piece of this but i get it nobody's
going to be calm about this and i have
no doubt that my haters are going to
come for me on this one uh but here is
more from the mental institution known
as msnbc here is uh rachel maddow on uh
the reaction the substance of what this
opinion says as as congressman raskin
was just explaining there which appears
to be uh
opening the door for bans on abortion
without any limits
yeah so rachel everything i know about
the court says to me that this opinion
is a legitimate true opinion it's not
some sort of deep fake it looks like a
court opinion it quacks like a court
opinion it talks like a justice alito
opinion and so i think what you've been
saying is absolutely right i mean put bo
starkly this is the hugest step back for
women in decades the hugest step back
for reproductive justice in decades
step back for women step back for
reproductive justice i mean reproductive
justice think about that word again it
doesn't matter exactly what you think
about abortion think about the way they
use words reproductive justice
does that guy know what an abortion is
does he know what an abortion is does he
know what an abortion looks like when
you do an abortion at six months
and that's reproductive
justice and women's rights and again
these are the same people who were
forcing people to be injected with
things a few months ago now they feel
that the government has no right to do
anything related to anyone's bodies it's
it's rather extraordinary because when
you don't have principles and you just
have a sort of amorphous set of ideas
you can basically get people to say
almost anything
but speaking of uh people saying and
perhaps doing almost anything
immediately after this leak happened
literally within 20 minutes of the leak
there were barricades going up at the
supreme court
and protesters were showing up outside
the building
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
don't don't
[Applause]
okay so first you have an absolute right
to protest in the united states that is
one of the most important things that
you can do as a free person in a free
country and as long as those people
remain peaceful if they want to stay out
there all night and day that is just
great if they want to voice their
opinion that is just great and
everything else the second it turns
violent which undoubtedly it will
whether it's today or tomorrow or next
week or somewhere else not outside the
steps of the supreme court building et
cetera et cetera then we got a problem
what i found interesting about that is i
wonder how many of those people
that were out there even know what
they're protesting because they i think
most of them think that abortion is now
illegal i don't think most of them think
that it is just kicked back to the
states and the state will make whatever
decision it sees fit so again if you
live here in florida and this decision
goes through and you are now pregnant
and you have been raped which is
unimaginably horrible
or
or you made a mistake
if that's the word you want to use or
you find out that the the fetus is going
to have some debilitating disease or
whatever your reasons are you have 15
weeks to make a decision here in florida
here in red
state florida that is the law that they
passed and it was actually pretty
uncontroversial here you didn't see a
ton of the the blue people in florida
going crazy about it you didn't see a
ton of the red people saying no it needs
to be six weeks it was something that
was roughly agreeable and i that's why
i'm very proud to live in this state and
i think that that's a pretty fair
estimation now some of you may say no we
wanted 12. and there might be some of
you that say 118 and some of you may
want six and i get that some of you want
zero
and probably some of you on eight months
but again we live in a society with a
lot of different people and we have to
figure out ways to maximize freedom
across
the board so look again those people can
protest and as long as they do it
peacefully that's fine now the problem
is that you guys know this the media and
the administration they are going to
subtly make sure that the heat is
constantly ramped up on this right this
is just like what they've done all we've
shown you many videos over the years of
uh all of these democrats
constantly sort of winking and nodding
at violence when it's their political
violence
and they're going to constantly tell you
that everything that republicans do or
conservatives do is backwards
and it's racist and bigoted and perhaps
archaic gensake
amazon told its employees today that
they would be providing a new workplace
benefit to allow
workers to travel to other states if
they need to for abortion procedures um
i'm curious what the white house thinks
of that whether that's something that is
um
appropriate as there are more
restrictions on abortion rights and um
and whether that's something that unions
should seek in collective bargaining
negotiations sure um well i don't have
any comments on a decision by a private
sector company we know our view on the
um archaic
abortion laws that we've seen put into
place across the country in some states
far too many states
i'm happy to check if there's more we
have god that woman i mean yeah she has
no opinion on companies in the private
sector doing things right like i'm
pretty sure if it was a company doing
something related to trans stuff or
whatever gender identity or blah blah
blah she'd have an opinion but you see
what she subtly did there which is that
these are archaic laws these are archaic
laws because people should have
abortions at any time whenever they want
because abortion is just good now
ironically the question is the right one
again
can a company say hey if you work for us
and we are based in this state let's say
we are based in alabama i'm just using
that as an example and we are based in
alabama you have a health care policy
in alabama are you allowed to cross
state lines and get an abortion
elsewhere if it is not allowed in
alabama now of course this is the beauty
of the united states and again i would
say to barbara streisand and rosie
o'donnell and all of the blue czech
lefties rob reiner and mark hamill who
are the other really horrible ones give
me some horrible lefties
there's enough of them
pick your own horrible lefty you at home
choose your own horrible hollywood lefty
they can fund
people getting on buses and mostly it's
going to be poor people and mostly it'll
be people of color and they can bus them
into california and they can put them up
at the four seasons and they can have
their abortions and then they can send
them back because
that's what they it would be doing
something with your own money and your
own resources and again that would allow
people to get abortions if it is that
important to you now
uh you know it's funny yesterday i was
really talking about how we're starting
to win we're entering this post woke
world there's a lot of good signs for
all sorts of things and so what's
unfortunate about what's just happened
and especially again because this has
happened because of a leak is that it's
going to sort of make us take our eye
off of some of the good things that are
happening say the mask mandates going
away say elon getting twitter
all the good stuff desantis fighting
disney et cetera et cetera
and we're going to all be focusing on
abortion which is which because of the
existential issues related to it is
something that is insolvable in some
ways and intractable in so many ways so
it's good like the hate is just going to
start bubbling up again right it's back
it's back we have to acknowledge that um
but also what it's going to do is this
is going to mask a whole bunch of
disastrous
policy stuff that the biden
administration has uh been doing for the
last year and a half whether it's on
censorship covert or student loans we've
got a little compilation for it
the mandate is not to adjudicate what is
true or false online or or otherwise um
it will operate in a non-partisan a
political manner uh it should not be
lost on anyone uh that uh there is a
dire need
for money
to continue to fund our needs on covet
on inflation has the white house
analyzed at all how much sorry student
loan forgiveness would impact inflation
i i know there's been outside analysis
of that but i don't have any internal
analysis at this point too
so those are just like three examples of
the disastrous stuff whether it's the
ministry of truth that they've now
started to put together so that they can
infringe on our ability to speak freely
and the first amendment rights or
whether it's just scaring us with more
covet nonsense or whether it's that they
want to take care of student loan which
just punishes people who actually paid
off their debt or for some reason you
want to pay off some rich kid who went
to uh say syracuse for 70 grand a year
you want to pay off his 280 000 loan
with other people's tax money so they
have failed us at virtually
every level right uh but it's not just
that uh those few things uh we also have
this disastrous inflation problem uh and
the immigration stuff which is a
disaster and now this is all becoming a
liability for joe biden so it's suddenly
like well wait a minute if they feel
they can fire up the base with the
abortion stuff perhaps that'll had a
little something to do with the leak
because the guy's got a whole bunch of
problems
it says that the president's poulter
astoundingly had sounded the alarm about
inflation and immigration becoming
political liabilities coupled with this
new polling that is out today that shows
that voters
trust republicans more believe they're
more better that they are better suited
to handle both of these issues so can
you speak to how the administration is
digesting this data including these
remarks from the pollster and and is
there a sense right now that there needs
to be some kind of force correction on
these two issues given that polling in
the midterms being just six months out
well let me first say that that report
was about
a range of pulling that goes back to
last year
including before
a number of events happened whether it
was the invasion
of russia into ukraine or even the um
the uptick of covet that we saw um late
in the summer and into the fall really
primarily in the fall okay so the point
here is the administration has disasters
at every level the war in ukraine like
just all of the stuff we all know this
inflation supply chain okay fine so we
have all these disasters all over the
place and one of the things that we now
know
for sure from polling and i can tell you
as a as a humble author who just went on
a book tour when i meet people out on
the streets and who come to my shows
i'm meeting a huge amount of people who
are now telling me dave i was a lifelong
democrat just like you i'm never going
to vote for a democrat again i'm not a
lefty anymore they either i'm a sort of
moderate conservative or i'm a
libertarian or a classical liberal some
some version of all that but but
wouldn't it be interesting if if the
leak
really was about scaring the [ __ ] out of
those people those people who have been
on the fence the bill maher types who
there's a huge swath of them there's a
huge swath of them they've been silenced
and they've been
cowed into irrelevance
but those are the people who could
decide the next election these sort of
disaffected liberals who have had it
with the progressives who have been on
their way
to say becoming conservative republican
whatever whatever phrase you want to use
on that whatever label you want to use
but now this this thing comes out and
then that pushes them all back because
abortion is just such a freaking
personal
powerful issue right uh but the disaster
is going to remain either way so even
and and also i don't i just don't think
you know we all have a set of issues we
all have let's say a list of 10 things
that are important to us and we we rank
them right so for some people foreign
policy might be the first thing that's
important to them for something some
people taxes are number four uh for some
people states rights are here or
whatever it might be we all sort of
order that in our own brain whether
we're thinking about it or not and those
are the things that move us on voting
they might get a whole bunch of people
who had abortion pretty down low to now
put that at number one so it's a little
hard to say which way this this will
move people
but
the issue is that we're all going to be
talking about abortion we got a whole
bunch of other problems uh there might
be an uh recession on the way i think
you put your fear in exactly the dilemma
you know i think a recession is at this
stage almost inevitable
because they don't control supply and
we've seen how volatile supply can be
with the uh shutdown in china um we also
see uncertainty about oil prices up and
down et cetera and so you know as i said
earlier it's a witch's brew and the
probability of a recession is i think
unfortunately very very high because
their tool is crude and all they can do
is control arrogant demand
and by the way you know some people are
going to be harmed earlier than others
but you know they have no choice they've
got to maintain credibility which to to
date they've done reasonably well
that guy who we showed you right there
on cnbc that ain't nobody that's former
vice chair of the federal reserve roger
ferguson basically saying that a
recession is inevitable so now instead
of focusing on hey what can we do to
save the economy which the democrats and
biden have basically destroyed we're all
going to be screaming about abortion and
ironically we're not even going to be
screaming about the honest issues
related to abortion we're just going to
be screaming whether abortion is legal
or not which again has nothing to do
with roe v wade so now i want to link
this to those good liberals because
these are the people now that are that
i focus on them a lot but really in some
ways they're going to be the key group
now they're going to be the key group
because they've been on their way to
going in the right direction but they
might fall back because of abortion
these are the people that biden needs
needs more than anything else
so you might remember or no this is just
a few days ago uh this is joe uh bill
maher and i know i play a lot of bill
maher clips but i think you get why i do
it uh this is bill maher who keeps
getting sort of most of the things right
two years late
talking about how bad the democrats have
been on the economy
the democrats they are in trouble the
economy shrank the last quarter we
didn't see that coming and you know when
it shrinks two quarters in a row that's
a recession plus we have horrible
inflation sometimes you get the feeling
the democrats are uh tanking on purpose
to get a better draft pick next year
i
i mean
inflation
gas right and food and rent have you
seen the price of chimneys they are
through the roof
that joke had been lying around for
hundreds of years nobody picked it up i
i picked it up
okay
so you see he's getting it
there's a lot of bad [ __ ] happening and
he's making jokes about it they got like
20 writers for that chimney joke pretty
good okay fine
now this is the same bill maher who
unfortunately voted for biden encouraged
his
uh viewers to vote for biden and of
course you may remember this clip that i
don't think he wants people to see
anymore this is when that orange man was
president and mar wanted a recession
because that would take out that orange
man right josh isn't the fed cutting
rates now just going to make the next
economic downturn worse what's your
prediction i've been hoping for a
recession people hate me for it but it
would get rid of trump so you shouldn't
name me for it i mean recessions are
really bad people lose their jobs and i
know and we shouldn't wish it's worth it
but uh i i don't i mean a recession is
always possible i don't see any
particular reason to think that it's
likely i think you know really aren't we
over due for one just no this by the
cycle of economics this is such a
misconception people sort of feel like
oh you know well about every eight years
or something you're supposed to have it
recessions don't come because they're
due recessions come because there's some
sort of overheating something goes wrong
in the economy
so he wanted a recession when he was
going to get rid of the guy that he
hated then he gets the guy he wants and
we're basically gonna have a recession
so once again you're just always late to
the party um and i guess it's easy to
call for a recession when you probably
have 100 million bucks i don't know how
much he has but it's more than anyone
watching this right now
more than me
um so you can you can weather the storm
on a recession but now they're realizing
how bad it is but that's why this thing
with the abortion thing is is so nuts
because was the whole machine just
handed something that is going to push
everybody back into their old way of
thinking about everything so it's like
man
mar you're right on inflation you're
right on how bad biden has been you're
right on free speech with him you're
right on all the woke stuff and crt and
the gender stuff but is this going to
push those liberals back to the left and
the real question is to go back to his
joke you know he was basically saying
hey are the democrats tanking it so that
they can get a better pick in next
year's draft well you know what bill and
this is the question man okay let's
pretend it's next year's draft you know
what next year's draft is 2024 it's most
likely desantis on one side and it's
most likely kamala on one side right
because it's not going to be biden so
let's say it's desantis or trump
or tim scott
or literally any republican
who are you going to vote for who are
you going to draft and i know you're
going to draft the wrong guy because i
basically have given up with you but i
haven't given up on the people that
watch you so that really is the problem
they might be tanking it they might be
tanking it intentionally because i think
they want to destroy the system but are
you just going to always make jokes
about the things that you help screw up
two years later this is what all the
liberals have to figure out uh but
we've got more from nbc this is not
msnbc this is nbc although it's
basically the same thing at this point
this is chuck todd who's a democrat
activist pretending to be a uh an
impartial host uh and uh he's realizing
that the dems are having problems
because they've gone so bananas left
taking a look at election results over
the past few decades it shows us a
flashing warning side for democrats as
the nation's urban world divide has
deepened democrats have increasingly
lost support in rural america in 1996
then president clinton he won a whopping
1117 counties rural counties including
all but 20 of iowa's 99 counties
basically he won half of the nation's
rural counties
but in 2008 barack obama won less than
half of that just 455 rural counties
even though he had won a popular vote by
seven points nationwide that's all the
rural counties he could win
fast forward to 2020 the number shrunk
again
joe biden won just 194 counties that's
just 17 percent of the total that bill
clinton won in 1996 and the latest nbc
news polling shows you that the problem
has not gone away it's gotten worse
trust me terry mcauliffe in virginia
knows this yes democrats have an
advantage in the urban areas 24 points
on the generic congressional ballot but
as you move out geographically the
democratic numbers shrink and the
republican numbers grow and grow big
time 34 points right now the number
appears to be growing
all right so the point is democrats have
a lot of problems and did this leak and
the way the media will frame it and
confuse people as to what actually is
happening and what roe v wade actually
is about and what's been going on in the
states who have already decided to make
their own laws around some of this stuff
does this just completely flip the board
and as i always say you got to give the
devil is due the system somehow always
stays one step ahead of us and perhaps
they did
at this very moment uh we shall see but
i i just don't know i don't think anyone
fully knows you know when ao aoc says
this thing about the majority the vast
majority of americans was that aoc or is
that ilhon either one that is the same
woman uh when they say that it's like i
don't know that that's actually true so
maybe this will push people the other
way
but man liberals
start getting it start getting it i have
to say guys this is the funniest show
we've ever done would you say this is
the funniest show in terms of pound for
pound laughter would this be the funny
this was definitely the funniest show
we've ever done uh we got some comments
from reubenreport.locals.com
zionist says that amazon has already
said they would fund quote abortion
tourism oh and she gave us a link to a
reuters headline amazon to reimburse u.s
employees who travel for abortions four
thousand dollars look
you may not like abortion
but if you are happy
and i assume you are that roe v wade is
going to be flipped and it's going to be
kicked back to the states
then the idea that a company could say
hey if we exist in a place that does not
allow abortion and we'll throw some
money to allow somebody to go to state
you may not love that you may not love
the personal choice of the company or
the personal choice of the person but i
think hopefully you'd be able to accept
the
decision that they made with within
their own capacity to make decisions
right
so that basically would be okay and
again i really don't think i'd love to
see some numbers on this and i assume
we're going to get them over the next
couple of weeks like how many states
truly without exception are going to
outlaw abortion i think it's going to be
very very few i think if florida has
done anything right and it's done an
awful lot right this 15-week thing makes
a lot of sense it really makes a lot of
sense and as i said earlier it wasn't
that controversial here because most
people know it makes a lot of sense
america mom says this is all theater
just like the orchestrated release of
the kavanagh accuser this is all about
november yeah i kind of think you're
right and that's why it's it's so
important it's so important to figure
out who leaked this
how did they do it how did the politico
people find it was this a clerk was this
a hack was this a justice
was it a clerk and the justice knew or
did not like someone's got to go to jail
be punished to the fullest extent of the
law the fact that this we just added
like an x factor into everything that's
going on in this country right now i
think we can shut down kovit officially
for a while so that i guess is nice um
but yeah messy messy and it does feel
like theater like we're all there's no
business like show business man and
we're all in a show and you have to just
do your best you can the best that you
can to stay sane throughout it jeannie
says just got a ticket to brea
and you're stoked very nice i think
there are literally when we started the
show today there were 10 tickets left
500 seat theater there were 10 tickets
left so it may be sold out already uh
brea is with uh prager oxnard is with
larry elder uh
phoenix is with blake masters and
charlie kirk denver is with brian callan
and san jose is with douglas murray and
then finally the big one june 2nd
with florida governor ron desantis look
at the red and the black and the white
at the plaza live in orlando
daverubin.com
events as always guys if you want to
chat uh with the community during the
show you go to reubenreport.locals.com
and once again guys we've got a cold
close for you and don't worry
you know sure this this was we were
there's a lot of big issues no doubt
about it a lot happening in the country
a lot going on regardless of what side
of the issues you're on at least we have
joe biden in charge and he knows what's
up parenthetically if you think about it
what was the reason why we led the world
beginning around nineteen five six and
seven and eight